la chronique culture du mercredi aurélia
de ici bonsoir bonsoir magique pour
commencer à voilà un plateau
exceptionnel ce soir avec deux artistes
magiciens dont astana vitaux bonsoir
vous êtes donc magicien professionnel
ainsi que olivier case indices on sort
magique flash donc ce soir vous venez
nous parler tous les deux d'un festival
qui a lieu samedi à voisins de quoi
s'agit-il quelle sera la programmation
eh bien il va y avoir beaucoup de choses
durant ce festival de magie il y aura
entre autres des ballons je crois des
ballons c'est sûr je crois oui des
heures parce que c'est un spectacle de
magie quand même oui mais le ballon
c'est magique enfin je me trouve quand
on verra peut-être après tout ça on a eu
les ballons ses genoux vous n'êtes pas
parti
imaginez il était tout petit comme ça
valait bien les ballons bah oui oui il y
aura des débats l'ont d'ailleurs il un
dieu sait si magique ça vient
d'apparaître site insiste il ya un
couteau dont la lame d'un couteau
peut-être un couteau ouais
pas de ballon tape couteau on n'est pas
loin bon allez vous lui avez fait peur
mais le coeur bien accroché par des
colons des ballons des colombes
et puis en tant que magicien il ya
toujours des foulards ou savait toujours
celle ci beaucoup l'art comme les
magiciens gîte et il y aura également
des cannes oui il y aura des cas et je
crois même on m'a même vie il y aura des
fleurs non olivier oui il ya un patou
vert pourquoi il ya non excusez moi
n'ont guère des fleurs non je suis
désolé on flaire parents les avaient pas
bien tu tu me le temps comme ça parce
que c'est interdit les fleurs un objet
de win qui avec deux têtes et cartons
d'accord c'est mieux s'il y avait des
gardiens joris et c'est mieux que les
fleurs il y aura la grande illusion
aussi d'ailleurs je crois grande
illusion
la grande illusion est ce que voulait
que vous interprète un tour de grande
illusion enfin en mode petit illusions
pour le pour le plateau oui hein ça vous
dit gilbert il ne s'arrête plus et c'est
c'est eh bien c'est bien parti à
l'extérieur des missions sais pas est ce
que vous connaissez le tour de la malle
des indes
pas du tout vous connaissez pas tout
dans la malle des indes du tout alors je
vous l'expliqué donc on a un jeu de
cartes
j'ai deux cartons rouges tout simplement
alors le tour de la maison c'est tout ça
que ça va se faire avec
écoutez ça va se faire avec un magicien
qui sera le roi de pique et son
assistante qui sera le vainqueur
ça doit être super alors il faut savoir
que dans ce tour le magicien qui hélas
est mis dans une boîte d'accord qui est
fermée à clé à cadenas etc
l'assistante vient up la rejoindre le
public et elle prend avec elle bien
entendu la boîte où le magicien est
enfermé et là d'un coup qu'est ce qui se
passe
hop là le magicien est certes it loud
complètement sorti de la boîte
oui parce que dans la boîte qui est ce
qu'on retrouve la ciste on retrouve
exactement
donc voilà il y aura de la grande de la
grande illusion une très sage je vais
préciser parce qu'en fait c'est
myrtilles merci à la colombie mais très
bien éduqué parce que là je suis désolé
mais si on va tout à bord mais allez-y
c'est une petite fierté c'est pas très
bien ce que tu as fait merci mécontents
quant aux myrtilles me retiens ça va pas
du tout la merci voilà c'est bon on
n'est pas en direct
j'espère bien sûr que non je vois bien
un jeu dans le mode axa chose est sûre
je vois tout va voyez alors ce spectacle
ce festival s'adresse à qui le public
alors vraiment tous les publics pour le
pour les plus jeunes à partir de 3 ans
eu quand même là je roulais jusqu'à
appris apa limite d'accord dans
l'organisation puisque ça démarre à 10
heures le matin des activités sur toute
la journée
dites nous donc à des ateliers des
stages d'initiation à la magie tout à
fait donc les jeunes pourront s'initier
donc à la magie donc à plusieurs
créneaux horaires il ya des séances de
sculpture sur ballons donc les enfants
comme les adultes pour repartir l'idée
des ballons il ya des magiciens amateurs
et professionnels qui sur plusieurs
stands font de la magie rapprochée c'est
le close up et donc il y a plusieurs
spectacles tout au long de la journée et
un gala de clôture de gala de clôture
deux grandes gueules de spectacles en
fait avec avec des grands noms de la
magie donc sont pas connus du grand
public mais qui sont vraiment des des
magiciens hors pair on va dire d'accord
donc un premier spectacle qui est autour
d'un plateau en fait d'artistes c'est ça
et le deuxième spectacle donc pour
clôturer cette journée avec l'artiste et
qui s'appelle bébel c'est ça qu'est ce
qui c'est qui pour vous
quel est son style c'est un grand car
thomas devienne un grand cartman
français donc il va nous émerveiller
avec des tours de cartes d'accord donc
avec s'en fout ça je me trompe à l'heure
actuelle que d'écarter un grand
spectacle de cars mais qui vaut le coup
et c'est un spectacle qui a adapté à la
scène ça veut dire qu'on peut voir un
large public il y aura des écrans géants
et la mise en scène et est adapté à un
public assez large donc mais c'est
vraiment un très très grand un très
grand spectacle est un très grand
magicien bébel si vous tapez sur
internet bébel vous verrez vraiment la
casquette avec les cartes
est ce que je dis c'est un grand
magicien qu'est ce qui fait un grand
magicien justement parce qu'il fait un
bon magicien et ben c'est quelqu'un qui
commet dire qui avec le même tour que
vous si vous faites un tour de magie
noire ou bébel le même tour de cartes
alors totalement lemelin aura un aspect
complètement différents mais assure si
c'est moi qui ai fait le tour de cartes
très différent ça c'est sûr on vous
donnait trois niveaux voilà c'est le
même temps le quai représenté par vous
par mois ou par bell ce sera pas du tout
la même chose alors que ça reste le même
matériel c'est vrai que souvent les gens
pensent que cdd des techniques visent
bien un truc là c'est pas qu'on soit là
c'est la face comme celle sur ce
spectacle c'est aussi une façon de se
produire est une façon de te fais
d'enveloppés tout ça autour du tour de
magie à bébel en plus c'est quelqu'un
qui inventent beaucoup de tours de
cartes aussi et vous scène qu'est ce qui
vous a amené à devenir magicien moi
c'était pas votre métier premier je
crois tout à fait donc ben comme on va
dire 90% des magiciens j'ai commencé
avec la boîte de magie
on a soudain dessous afin annuel et puis
de fil en aiguille on se dira m magicien
professionnel mais c'est pas si facile
que ça donc pendant plusieurs années
j'ai fait d'autres d'autres activités
j'étais animateur en centre de loisirs
ce qui m'a permis de
d'être très à l'aise avec les enfants
donc j'aime beaucoup le public enfants
jeu différente avec les enfants tout à
fait c'est vrai que beaucoup de magicien
je le vois au sein du club
beaucoup de magicien appréhende ce
public là pourquoi et bien parce que le
public enfant est assez difficiles et
j'avais pensé linverse main comme ils
sont plus innocent si ça marche c'est là
où un adulte va plus ou moins de
réserves et s'ils voient des choses
aussi non un enfant doit par areva puis
si un enfant s'ennuie mais il va se
balader ils s'ennuient consultera le
respect de rester et l'applaudir a
gentiment c'est un bon test en même
temps les enfants comme ça mais moi
j'adore j'adore c'était vraiment donc
les mon spectacle spécialement pour les
enfants à 11 heures du matin
donc pour les plus matinaux n'hésitez
pas à venir il ya à mon spectacle je
passe aussi le soir avec des colombes
avec liberty c'est un progrès que
martine martin tuer dit-il soit propre
quand même disque loi dénommée fera un
effort dit cela voilà très bien et vous
les oliviers dits magiques flash hague
alors qu'est-ce qui est-ce qui vous a
mené vous aussi à la magie qu'est ce que
ça représente la magie pour vous et bien
aujourd'hui la magie représente beaucoup
de choses je me suis j'ai essayé
beaucoup différentes d'autres or j'ai
été mangé aussi un métier entre
guillemets traditionnel d'avant mais
j'étais aussi les trapézistes jongleurs
je vais également des sculptures ballon
un peu tout ça et c'est vrai que j'ai
trouvé dans la magie c'est
c'est un coffre rempli de choses vers la
magie c'est inépuisable on peut
s'intéresser à ben c'est une source
intarissable on peut on peut on peut
trouver énormément de choses à faire
dans la magie donc moi ce que j'aime
dans la magie c'est que je dire voilà
comme vous êtes tout à l'heure stan par
peur des balles qui invente des tours on
peut inventer des choses
la seule limite giresse c'est
l'imagination c'est la création
exactement tout n'a pas été fait en
magie pourtant pour avoir l'impression
vous doutez que fois que ça alors ça a
été vue on peut les réinterpréter bien
sûr surtout qu'aujourd'hui on a des
évolutions technologiques qui se font et
plus qu'on peut qu'on peut placer dans
la magie du coup faire des numéros qui
sont qui sont vraiment différents des
votants on a je pense qu à différents
stades de majorque faire la maj
effectivement que des cartes utilisent
également des moyens techniques beaucoup
plus sophistiqué on peut faire encore
d'autres choses
et qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand on est
sur scène face à un public année des
yeux émerveillés
qu'est ce que ça vous procure un grand
stress au départ forcément puisqu'on n'a
pas droit demont n'a pas besoin de se
rater en magie mais un grand bonheur
après ce que serait qu'on amène vraiment
du plaisir aux gens on les emmène dans
un rêve et c'est vrai que faire rêver
les gens ses fonctions c'est la plus
belle chose et puis ça vous avez des
moments de solitude justement de rater
un tour et ne pas savoir comment
rattraper après au début peut-être au
début ça m'est arrivé une fois ça n'est
arrivé qu'une fois parce que justement
je me disais c'est ce que j c'est qu'on
n'a pas de fils est malheureusement donc
après on apprend à se faire un petit
fils je dirais mais mais bon ça qu'après
avec le temps on apprend c'est un vrai
métier j'irai la magie c'est on peut pas
on peut pas dire magicien comme ça du
jour au lendemain on sait s'il ya
beaucoup de travail ça demande beaucoup
d'ailleurs ça fait à peu près sept ans
vous n'êtes que je suis professionnel je
veux que vous avez un spectacle qui que
vous produisez donc régulièrement tout à
fait que ce soit pour les cee les
mairies ou même simplement la gt je sors
d'un goûter d'anniversaire
j'ai eu un peu de route mais j'ai eu un
goûter d'anniversaire où j'ai fait une
petite animation pour les enfants alors
se voit là ça peut être une animation
pour les mariages pour les arbres de
noël le mois de décembre c'est très
chargé on va dire donc voilà c'est
vraiment toute sorte de public avec un
spectacle qui est qui est différent en
fonction de la demande on va dire mais
qui est toujours interactif et pour les
colons qui reviennent un peu votre
réalité vertu c'est le fil rouge merci
voilà qui aurait été avec nous également
ce soir merci à tous les gens va
redonner l'étape oui donc c'est samedi à
partir de 10h à l'espace culturel
decauville à voisin vous avez ici toutes
les coordonnées pour vous inscrire et
enfin vous réservez pardon et puis alors
il ya une partie extérieure une partie
intérieure a priori il fera beau samedi
vous quand vous souhaitez alors même
s'il fait pas beau il faut venir parce
que tout ce qui était prévu l'extérieur
il ya une très grande salle qui est
prévu rien qu il fasse bon qu'il la
salle n'est pas occupé quoi qu'il arrive
et donc on peut tout rapatrier tous les
stands voilà merci